A wild Markimoo has appeared! Or has it...
Hello everyone! My name is Markiplier! And welcome back to Try to Laugh challenge.
Now I've been away for quite some time
You could call it exile but now I am back I said I was not coming back for quite some time. BUT IM BACK...
(FOIN EXHAIL)
I've been staring at my nude self (... ewww)
for far too long...
So we're gonna wash it away with some funny fails from kids...
...doing funny things... (Y not adults?)
Welcome to try not to laugh challenge.
...don't laugh.
(Sexy silence)
(Sexy transition)
-What? What could possibly go wrong- (idk)
-Ok, Slam dunkin' ._.
-oh, OH OH LOOK OUT! O_O
OOOH HOHOHOHOHO (MARK IS SANTA!!!)
(The Markimoo slowly dies of laughter)
(Little kiddy dies) (RIP Kid Buddy 200x-2018)
Oh! Ho-ho!!
*Sniff*
Oh! HO HO!
What was that? 20 seconds?, I think we have a new record for the try not to laugh challenge. (Good job.)
Well, uninfortunately >_> (wait what?)
That's all the time I have for this episode!
So thank you, everybody so much watching and as always I'll see you...
...In the next video!!!
BUH-BYE!!!
HEHE, MARK IS TOOO FUNNY!!! WAIT!!!
IT'S ETHAN!! MAGIC!!! OOHHHHHH.... I think.. lol
Okay see ya!! )
U NEED TO SUB TO HIM!!! CAN WE HIT ONE BILLON LIKES?!! ( ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿°̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ͜ʖ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿°̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ ̿ )